Shazam and Superman will appear on the silver
screen together in Spring 2019 - but it's
probably not the Man of Steel you know and
love.
Potential spoilers for Shazam! ahead!
We Got This Covered claims that sources in-the-know
say that Superman will appear in Shazam!,
the upcoming Zachary Levi-led DC superhero
flick.
Shazam! tells the story of a 14-year-old orphan
named Billy Batson who meets a mystical wizard,
obtains the powers of six different immortal
elders, and earns the ability to turn into
an adult superhero whenever he utters the
word "Shazam!"
Are you for real?!"
"SAY IT!"
"Okay … Shazam?"
The movie looks like a cheery remedy to the
doomy, gloomy DC Extended Universe - but with
the Man of Steel reportedly making an appearance
in the movie, Shazam! will also feel like
it truly belongs in that Universe, for better
or for worse.
But before any DC enthusiasts start jumping
for joy or creating Shazam and Superman fan
art, we have some disappointing news: the
actor popping up in Shazam! may not be the
Superman star most people are familiar with.
We Got This Covered claims, citing anonymous
insiders, that Henry Cavill won't be the man
playing the Metropolis Marvel in Shazam!
This is reportedly due to Cavill's disinterest
in returning to the role, which he first stepped
into for 2013's Man of Steel.
The outlet further speculates that the, quote,
"ongoing alleged difficulties" between Warner
Bros. and DC Films executives and Cavill motivated
the decision.
The Hollywood Reporter previously reported
that Cavill had allegedly cut ties with Warner
Bros. and was actively looking for a way out
of the DCEU and his role as Superman.
Batman star Ben Affleck was said to be doing
the same - leaving the studios without two
of their biggest superhero stars.
A Warner Bros. spokesperson, however, later
claimed,
"We have a great relationship and great respect
for Henry Cavill that continues to remain
unchanged.
Additionally we have made no current decisions
regarding any upcoming Superman films."
If Cavill is indeed out of the running, who
will portray Superman alongside Shazam?
Well, word is that Shazam! is using a body
double of the same size and stature as Cavill
and not including the character's face in
the scene.
How will that work?
Reportedly, the sequence in question sees
Billy fulfilling his foster brother Freddy's
wish for Billy to appear as Shazam at their
school, proving that Freddy is friends with
a real-life superhero.
Just after Shazam walks into the room, Superman
follows behind, officially making Freddy the
coolest kid in school.
Cavill, for his part, has kept pretty quiet
about his relationship status with the DCEU.
He only broke his silence by posting to Instagram
shortly after The Hollywood Reporter's story
went live a bizarre video of himself wearing
a "Krypton Lifting Team" shirt and holding
up an action figure of himself as Superman
while a dog-bark version of "The Blue Danube"
played in the background.
In other words: No comment.
His manager, Dany Garcia, then went on the
record to state that, metaphorically speaking,
the Superman cape is still in Cavill's closet,
saying,
"[Warner Bros.] has been and continues to
be our partners as they evolve the DC Universe."
Fellow DCEU actor Jason Momoa, who made a
splash in his Aquaman solo movie in December,
has also maintained that Cavill is "absolutely"
not done playing Superman and that he is definitely
not leaving the DCEU.
So perhaps Cavill is tied up trying to renegotiate
terms of a potential new contract with Warner
Bros., or he's attempting to secure producing
credits and the ability to sign off on directors
and writers for Superman films, as various
reports have suggested.
He very well could be playing a waiting game,
standing firm and not stepping back into his
Clark Kent role until his requests are met.
Or maybe Cavill actually does appear in Shazam!,
in a hilarious cameo, and all these insider
reports are just a smokescreen?
It's no Deadpool, but Shazam! looks like it's
game to pull off such a stunt:
"Oh hey, what's up?
I'm a superhero."
We'll all found out the truth about Superman's
appearance in Shazam! when the film opens
in theaters on April 5th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
DC superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.